what's going on guys this is rob and
we're probably a little bit late on this
upload but today is our beyond omega
level series where we break down those
powerful characters and comics and since
doctor strange came out already
naturally we have to cover him but as
powerful as the mcu version of doctor
strange is he pales in comparison to his
power level in the comics which is
normally the case with the movies versus
the comics and so for this video we're
specifically talking about doctor
strange as he was depicted prior to
having his power reduced in 2009. so if
you hear anyone talking about what's
referred to as pre-retcon doctor strange
or classic doctor strange this is the
version we're talking about so doctor
strange was created by stan lee and
steve ditko and first appeared in
strange tales number 110 in 1963. now
most of you are probably familiar with
his origin but if not stephen strange
was a skilled but arrogant surgeon whose
career was destroyed when he was in a
car accident that shatters the bones in
his hands and leaves him with nerve
damage so severe that he can no longer
perform surgery now desperate to get his
career back doctor strange begins a
quest to find any possible means to
repair his hands but this leads him to
spend all of the vast fortune he's made
over his medical career leaving him
destitute and no closer to repairing his
hands everything changes when he
overhears a conversation about a
mysterious man known as the ancient one
who lives in the himalayas and has vast
healing powers so stephen of course
seeks out the ancient one who initially
refuses to heal him because of his
hubris but after strange humbles himself
and agrees to become his disciple the
ancient one begins training him in the
mystic arts now over the years strange
would become sorcerer supreme of earth
and would continue becoming more and
more powerful until he relinquished the
title of sorcerer supreme and brian
michael bendis's new avengers number 54.
now since that time doctor strange has
regained the mantle of sorcerer supreme
but his power has not come close to the
level it was prior to him being
retconned now like many of the
characters we cover on this series
coming up with a list of powers for
doctor strange is difficult because his
only real power is his skill in
performing magic spells and using
magical artifacts however because he is
so adept at magic he's able to do a wide
variety of things and this version of
doctor strange is so powerful that he
could basically do anything he wants
hence why marvel decided to nerf his
power level later on but a partial list
of his abilities would include flight
time travel protective shields astral
projection telepathy telekinesis blasts
of mystical energy and teleportation but
as we often do i think the best way to
get an idea of how powerful classic
doctor strange was is to discuss some of
his more impressive feats so in one
instance a sorcerer named stigero had
basically been transformed into a living
start and doctor strange caused the star
to collapse into a black hole and throws
it into the cosmic wheel of change which
is basically just a plot device that was
created by the in-betweener to reshape
the universe but the takeaway point here
is that doctor strange was able to
survive being in close proximity to a
star which is an impressive feat in and
of itself but not only was he able to do
that he was also able to create a black
hole and then destroy it now speaking of
the in-betweener if you're not familiar
with him he's a cosmic abstract in the
marvel universe that represents the
concept of duality and is capable of
high level reality warping and if you
want to know more i do have a biondo
mega level video about him that you can
always check out but regardless at one
point doctor strange finds himself
trapped in the in-betweener's reality
warping and is subjected to intense
mental torture which eventually drives
him insane however he eventually breaks
free of the in-betweener's grasp by
summoning the cosmic abstracts of lord
chaos and master order defeating the
in-betweener and then imprisoning him so
here we end up seeing doctor strange
operating on the level of cosmic
entities which places him extremely high
on the power hierarchy of marvel comics
as these entities represent the concepts
that hold the universe together now
shortly after this he's able to change
the direction of the wheel of change
which undid all the changes to the
universe the in-betweener had brought
about so this basically represents
doctor strange being able to alter the
history and fabric of the universe in
another instance doctor strange
interacts with the beyonder in both
pre-retcon and post-retcon forms with
his pre-retcon version being vastly more
powerful and able to manipulate matter
and warp reality to the point that he
could destroy entire universes with a
single thought now when the two interact
doctor strange creates a veil of
illusion that traps the beyonder until
doctor strange frees him from it and he
remarks that he could have left him in
the illusion for all of eternity if he
wished and this statement is verified by
the beyonder himself furthermore dr
strange is able to undo the reality
warping the beyonder had done meaning
that he himself possesses vast reality
warping powers and as we've seen over
the course of this series once we
establish that a character can alter
reality we know they're way beyond omega
level as there's basically nothing
outside of their capabilities doctor
strange's list defeats do not end there
when confronted by the living tribunal
who is widely considered to be the
second most powerful regularly occurring
character in marvel comics only being
surpassed in power by the one above all
dr strange encountered this guy and the
living tribunal trapped him within a
spell called the roving rings of ragador
which he proclaimed no sorcerer could
escape but dr strange breaks the spell
with the greatest of ease much to the
surprise of the living tribunal who
remarks that he'd never seen it done
before and finally doctor strange had
faced the concept of death itself unites
with the cosmic entity eternity and in
doing so gets over his fear of death and
therefore becomes death meaning that he
will no longer age and is effectively
immortal unless killed in battle now
there are nearly countless examples of
classic dr strange's powers but some
others that we haven't mentioned yet
include negating the cosmic winds that
were strong enough to topple planets
from their orbits and he's been able to
defeat ridiculously powerful beings like
dormammu and nightmare in their own
realms where they're basically
omnipotent he's also defeated
shumagorath who's another nearly
omnipotent being that's conquered entire
universes in the multiverse i also have
beyond omega level videos on dormammu
nightmare and schumer gorath if you want
to learn more about why being able to
beat those three guys is a testament to
how insanely powerful dr strange was at
his peak but yeah living forever never
aging well living forever until he died
summoning cosmic entities and warping
reality classic doctor strange was a
ridiculously overpowered and well beyond
omega level character and of course i
know that there are a lot of feats that
i didn't list here but i tried to go
over the most impressive and really what
else can you add to make him seem more
powerful than this i don't really know
you know what let me know post it down
in the comments section
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace
you